hot breath um unfortunately
i i haven't been able to do it this year
because of cobit
uh so we've had yeah since february
the tuesday morning thing hadn't gone on
for the s
atlanta mission homeless guys but
you know michelle i i guess i would say
it's it's the way you prioritize
prioritize your life
um and i always go back to several years
ago
somebody was interviewing me about
something and the lady said
she said okay you write books you paint
and you draw
you host game shows you do stand up
you act which one are you
and i said well those are all things i
do and i love
what i do i i feel like i'm the most
blessed guy in the world because
i made a fabulous living doing something
i would have done it for free i i mean i
i would have that's how much i enjoy it
but i said those are things i do it's
it's not who i
am who i am
is i'm a husband and i'm a dad
and i'm a son and i'm a brother and i'm
a person of this community
and i'm a child of god that's who i am
so what i do
may change many many times but
who i am hopefully stays consistent
across
that thing like one year like i would
you know i would i was lucky i had the
financial resources because of success
that i could do shows and then i i would
lease a little
private plane and i would fly home and
i'd get home at two in the morning i
take my
kids to school i did that for 15 years
i'd fly to st louis do a show
fly back to atlanta get there two in the
morning get up at six and take my kids
to school
and then that next day fly to
minneapolis i mean that was just my life
wow but i grew up without a dad my dad
left and so for my kids more important
than my career
i didn't want my kid because when your
parents not there you just feel like
you're not worth sticking around for
and i'm like all right no matter what i
do for a living i never want my kids to
feel that way
and so they were the priority so i just
found a way to work
you know around them i i learned you
know my dad was married six times i
i saw the destruction that left behind
and you know so when i was on the road i
was like
i'm not going out to the clubs i'm not
hanging out at the bar i'm finishing the
show
and i'm going back to my hotel room and
order room service